-How are you?
-I'm well.
-I am so happy
to see you, always.
And, you know,
we already talked about
our Michael Cohen stuff tonight.
-Whew.
-So we got that out of the way.
But, you know, people
don't realize there's a cost.
There's a cost for everyone.
And I think that everybody
who was on television
this morning
had to pay that cost --
you particularly.
You were
on "Kelly" this morning.
-Yeah.
-And this happened while you
were getting interviewed.
-She thought
for years and years and years
and found herself
kind of on autopilot, and --
-Special report.
Michael Cohen testifies.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you very much.
-How dare they!
-I'm ready to zip it
at any moment.
-They should let you now
go on Congress
and say what you were gonna say.
Yeah.
-Oh, God. I get agita
just, like, thinking of that.
-But this is a wonderful show,
in its second season now.
Three moms who commit a crime
and then
the repercussions of that.
Do you enjoy --
Do moms come up to you now
and say that that
looks like an interesting way
to go about things?
[ Laughter ]
-Moms, women, yes.
People find the show
very empowering.
It's sisters, best friends
having each other's back
no matter what happens.
So people are like, "I just --
I love how they're taking things
into their own hands."
And I'm like, "Well, I mean,
they're doing
really stupid stuff."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, like,
you know, within reason.
-Do you think having done it
for a couple years --
How do you think
you'd be at crime?
-I think --
I think I would be a little bit
smarter than my character.
-Oh, that's nice.
That's good, yeah.
-But then --
But maybe not --
You know, when I had to make
a quick decision,
I might make mistakes.
But I think I would cover
my tracks a little bit better.
-All right, that's good.
-Yeah.
-And you have
two incredible co-stars,
both of whom have been here --
Retta and Mae Whitman.
And they talk a lot.
I hope it's true.
They say that you were very
close, the three of you.
-You hope it's true.
-Well, I would hate
if you said now like,
"No, the minute they say 'cut,'
we go our separate ways."
-No, we've been texting
each other all day long.
They are two of my best friends
and amazing actresses.
I couldn't be luckier.
Yeah, we text each other
till like 2:00 in the morning.
Retta will finally be like,
"I have to go to bed. Stop."
And we're all sending selfies
of ourselves laying in bed.
-Your mom was not a criminal,
but you had
a very interesting mom.
[ Laughter ]
Your mom was a hypnotherapist.
-Yeah, she was not a criminal.
[ Laughter ]
-But I can imagine,
as a kid, like,
having a mom
as a hypnotherapist,
was that a cool -- did you --
could you appreciate that
that was cooler than most moms?
-It was. It was sort of
a neighborhood trick.
She would practice on us
when she was learning,
and so we would have
the neighborhood kids come over,
and we would be like --
you know, go through the process
of putting them in hypnosis,
and then we would be like,
"You're gonna forget
the number 5,"
and they'd be like,
"Okay, wake up.
Now count your fingers."
"One, two, three, four,
six, seven -- no way!"
Like, "No way!"
[ Laughter ]
"No way.
Wait, one, two."
And we'd be like, "Ha ha!
We did it!"
-I mean, that would be the
coolest thing in the world.
-It was cool.
I'm sure we were all faking it,
but, you know...
[ Laughter ]
It seemed cool.
-Last time you were here,
we talked about "Mad Men"
and the end of that show.
You -- I still
can't believe this story.
Your agent did not want you
to take the part
of Joel -- uh, Joan.
-Yes.
Or Joel.
-Or Joel.
[ Laughter ]
Said, "I think both of these
are bad for you."
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I mean, at the time,
AMC didn't have any programing.
-Sure.
-And it was a period piece,
and they just didn't think
I was gonna make them any money.
And they just -- they weren't --
I decided, I said, "I love it.
I really --
I just feel really, really
strongly about it."
And they were like,
"That's so great.
No one wants
to work with you here."
-Wow! So you fully got let go
by your agency?
-Yeah, I did.
-Wow. That's amazing.
-Yeah.
-But also kind of great, right?
'Cause then you didn't have
to give them commission on it.
-That's true.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is -- this, to me,
is such a cool story.
You guys had to --
There was a long delay
between when you shot the pilot
and when you started the show.
And so you knew you had a job,
which is a thing --
not a lot of actors
live in that moment
where they're about
to start a job.
And so you then took on
another job
that was not
an acting job at all.
-We had this about a year
where we were being held,
and Matt Weiner,
the creator of the show,
was still working on
"The Sopranos,"
and so we couldn't work
on anything else
'cause we were
in this holding pattern,
and I had always wanted
to be a florist.
-Uh-huh.
-So I went to a local florist
that I really admired,
and I said,
"Would you ever
take on an intern
that I could learn
from your designers?"
And they kind of looked at me
like I was crazy.
And they were like,
"Well, I mean, we could use
some extra help
at Mother's Day."
And I was like, "Okay.
Well, I'll just do that."
So they hired me
for a short amount of time,
and I did a couple holidays
in the meantime.
-Did you ever have friends
who came in
and saw you as a florist
and were like, "Oh, no."
-Yeah, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
No, quite -- quite often,
they would be coming in
to buy flowers for their wives,
and I remember my friend
Craig Bierko came in,
and he went -- "Oh -- hey."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Oh."
And I was like,
"No, it's -- it's okay.
I think I have a job.
I just have always
wanted to do this."
And now he's like, "That was
so badass when you did that."
[ Laughter ]
Like a badass florist.
-Yeah.
But it's true,
because I think, like,
as an actor like, you never --
you'll like --
You get a chance to, like,
pretend to be a florist,
but to actually
get to be a florist
is probably a lot cooler.
-I thought
I was pretty good at it, too.
I was taking orders, getting --
you know, sending things out.
I was kind of like --
I was --
-And I would imagine
high-pressure because --
Well, I do, because, I mean,
if a guy is calling
to get flowers for his wife,
you don't want to blow that
for him.
I feel like he's already
in trouble, probably.
-People come in for, like,
either really sad reasons,
bad reasons,
or really happy reasons.
-Right.
-There's not an in between.
-No one's like, "It's Tuesday.
I'm gonna go get flowers."
-Yeah. You're sort of like,
"Ooh-ooh. What'd you do?"
Like, "How big should this be?"
Like, "How many
do we want to get here?"
-And then, I want to ask about
this because I'm assuming that,
you know,
you've done a lot of things,
but "Mad Men" must be a show
people ask you about
all the time.
And does it get tiring
hearing about it or not?
-No, it's fantastic.
You know, it's funny.
People are very sweet about it,
and they'll come up and be like,
"You must hate this,
but your show, like,
changed my life."
And like, "Your character
was so inspiring."
I'm like, "Yeah, I hate that."
You know?
Like, that's terrible.
It's so nice to hear.
And the way people watch TV now,
people are sometimes
just discovering it now.
-Of course.
-And people
are still binge-watching it
or rewatching it.
So I still get to have it
in my life all the time,
which is really great.
-That's really great.
Well, I'm certainly happy
to have it in mine.
I'm so happy to have you here.
Thanks for being back.
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-Always great to see you.